what's the biggest difference between
Steve uh how do you say his last name is
it Coker Steve Coker
I'm sorry Scott Coker and Dana White
what's the difference between the two of
them
um I think um
it's uh I mean Dana's Dana's just Dana's
a on a different level when it comes to
the celebrity you know like Dana's a
huge huge name Dana is is the when he
speaks people listen when he speaks it
is it is mixed martial arts that's what
people you know take any because he's
been doing it doing it for so much
longer
um you know Dana's a little bit more
Brash um Scott's a little bit more a
little bit more reserved so there's pros
and cons to both of those you know from
uh from a medium PR perspective I'm sure
you could talk to the UFC about that but
um you know
um but I I will say I think
I think Scott Coker does take growing
Bellator seriously but not as serious as
Dana I think Dana eats sleeps and
breatheses it it is his identity it is
his lifestyle it is him the UFC is Dana
White and Dana White is the UFC and
that's a beautiful thing I got a crazy
uh question for you and crazy idea
I don't even have this in my thing I'm
just thinking about it so I'm looking at
what bellator's Top Line Rev Avenue is
right now okay it's not a big number 80
million 100 million on what they're
doing per year I mean obviously UFC is
doing a lot more you know what would be
crazy
it would be very crazy you know how Dana
says look you want to do this go start
your own League see how hard it is and
he's right it's very very hard it's very
very hard
imagine if a person with the personality
of Dana goes and buys Bellator and
promotes Bellator and puts the you know
marketing eyeballs and I know a couple
guys that are big trolls that are very
loud if some of them were to buy it it
would be a very interesting competition
between two leagues student obviously
Dana's got a lead by a mile and a half
it's not even close yeah but if you were
to get somebody with a big personality
to get Bellator who does the eyeballs
and the marketing
I mean you look I mean how many how many
Dana whites are out there Vince McMahon
is one yeah Dana White's one who else
you put at that level uh uh I don't know
if Don King may be at his Peak back in
the days let's just say you put it down
you know uh uh I don't know who else you
put on that level you're promoting
promoter goes listen to be that you have
to can you imagine like you're the boss
of badass you know mother I mean you're
the boss of people that on any given day
camp whoop
99.9999999 of people's Tales anywhere in
the street fight right these guys are
people so so then imagine managing
leading negotiating saying No this is
the way or the highway you don't do this
I'm okay I'm gonna do that's not that's
not everybody's job only a few people
can do that job right yeah and you take
wrestling versus you know UFC wrestling
gets big egos but they don't know how to
fight like UFC does UFC is Big Egos and
they know how to fight and you're
leading them and you're set getting it
straight there's not too many Dana
whites but if some people claim they can
really do it better than UFC there's a
Bellator you can go by and do something
with that yeah no and it's uh I mean
yeah Dana's just he he wants to be he
wants to be bigger than the NFL he wants
to be bigger than the MLB you know he's
in he's you know decades behind
obviously those guys those what NFL
started and what he wants to be big MLB
yeah yeah he wants to be I mean 50
people he hasn't told me that but yeah
that's that's kind of you you feel it
that's it and that's and that's the kind
of that's just the kind of mentality
that that you you want in your your boss
you know like that's that's what I
resonate with and that's in my meeting
with my first phone call with him I just
you know I said hey I want to be a good
thing for your organization I promise
you you have never signed a guy that is
more equally yoked with you and told him
that yes and he hung up on me
what do you mean he hung up on me and
called Hunter Campbell yeah who is who
is his who is his right hand man yeah
you know so then he called me back and
then you know a couple days later we you
know got a got a contract figure it out
Michael so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]